welcome to water's world i'm jesse
waters cracking the code that's the
subject of tonight's waters words
there's something missing america
besides my book on the new york times
bestseller list it's fine we had a good
run
what's missing is the media mob fixated
on florida and kovid what changed
florida coveted cases went way down
florida kicked its summer surge good
news less sick citizens
extra extra read all about it
but the national news won't run it
the media mob won't tell you the rest of
the florida story because it had a happy
ending
see if the plot line changes and goes
against the narrative the press skips to
the next act
and the next act is this
if you're unmasked or unvaxed you're a
deadly weapon
children are not just suffering and
dying at greater rates right now they're
spreading coveted throughout the
population at higher numbers
anti-masking doesn't just affect schools
but our society as a whole people do not
get to walk around shooting loaded
firearms randomly into crowds and people
are not entitled to turn themselves into
deadly biological weapons by spraying
disease-laden aerosols wherever they
choose randomly killing innocent people
if you don't play by the left's rules
rules that have zilch to do with science
you'll be deemed a public health threat
kobod's not a threat you are
you're a bioweapon
you're an ar covid19
the government used the threat to public
health to strip you of your first
amendment rights freedom of speech
freedom of association
churches were shuttered interstate
travel restricted
voting was altered prisons emptied
these emergency powers fundamentally
changed america just because of a threat
to public health
a virus so threatening that the survival
rate was 99 percent
now that we have the facts the threat's
gone
but the emergency powers linger
follow along here because this is where
the danger lies
just months ago president biden said
this today we're
taking steps to confront not just the
gun crisis
but what is actually a public health
crisis
the cdc director quickly followed
this is clearly one of those moments one
of those issues that is harming
america's health something has to be
done about this
for the very first time the cdc is
funding a new surveillance program of
hospitals tracking americans coming into
ers with survivable gunshot wounds
they'll add them up and make their case
and if history is a guide the government
will deem gun violence a public health
threat
and use its emergency powers to limit
your second amendment rights
judges have to hold the line against
this coming power grab
the propaganda for the grabs has been
mounting the masses have been deluded by
it
military style semi-automatic assault
weapon
otherwise known as just a rifle
well the fbi released its 2020 crime
report massive rise in homicides but
let's go deeper
what's the murder method in a country of
over 300 million people last year just
454 murders were committed by rifle
some lever action pump action some i
guess ar-15s but more murderers used
their fists and their feet
and almost four times more people died
from knives than so-called assault
rifles a fake phrase by the way the ar
in ar15 actually stands for
armalite rifle the brand
so here's the point
over 8 000 homicides last year involved
handguns
these are the self-defense weapons of
choice in america especially among inner
city gangs who are responsible for a big
chunk of the body count
revolvers glocks very easy to conceal
so why doesn't the left harp on handguns
if that's the firearm doing all the
damage something to think about and
discuss on another show
you'll never find fairness on the left
look all you want you'll go cross-eyed a
great example
crazy california released the man who
tried to assassinate ronald reagan
john hinckley jr was a freak who tried
to impress actress jody foster by
killing the president
reagan barely survived the bullet
stopped an inch from his heart
but the would-be assassin's been paroled
was living in virginia but the public's
lost track of him he could be anywhere
in less than a year he'll be released
from all court supervision nobody
monitoring his meds travels or
communications
so shoot a president in the heart and
years later you're a free man
the system says you're not crazy you're
no threat
but if you question the election or the
cdc
i'm sorry sir
you're going to have to come with me
america feels like bruce willis and 12
monkeys
we appreciate your volunteering
you're a very good observer cole
thank you
a 3.5 trillion dollar bill costs nothing
the borders secure and
what's afghanistan
we did it today
the extraordinary success of this
mission
was due to the incredible skill
bravely
and selfless courage of the united
states military and our diplomats
and intelligence professionals
extraordinary success
everything costs more now trucks fuel
food but the geniuses in washington
claim it's all going away soon don't
worry
experts believe and the data shows that
most of the price increases we've seen
are were expected and expected to be
temporary not so fast
dollar tree is breaking the buck the
store where nearly everything sells for
one dollar is now raising prices by up
to 50 cents on some items to cover
rising costs so the dollar store is now
the dollar fifty store and it is not
going back down
everything's inflated
well except cnn's ratings
john nolte at breitbart has a great
piece
despite massive news events bottom falls
out of cnn's quarterly ratings
not a single cnn program averaged over a
million viewers not a single cnn program
cnn's highest rated show cuomo prime
time came in a humiliating 23rd place
tucker the five hannity one two three
nulty writes
we all know what's happening here on top
of the hideous behavior of deviants like
chris cuomo and cnn legal analyst
jeffrey toobin on top of the credible
sexual assault claim against don lemon
cnn lol is dealing with a massive
credibility crisis
over and over cnn lol has been exposed
as a fake news outlet that trolls and
lies and deliberately spread conspiracy
theories the end result is that during a
world-changing news quarter practically
no one tunes into cnn lol because no one
trusts cnn lol not even leftists
we reported last week chris cuomo was
accused of grabbing a producer's bud at
an abc party in front of her husband
and cop to it in writing
the highest rated anchor on cnn
embroiled in a sexual harassment scandal
that's news
but the mob spiked it
abc cbs nbc msnbc and of course cnn all
ignored the story
this is why corporate media is dying
they don't cover the news they cover it
up
the networks did the same thing with
john durham not a peep from abc cbs nbc
after crooked hillary's lawyer got
indicted for lying to the fbi
concocting the trump russia hoax
breaking news alerts any time a trump
associate was charged in the witch hunt
but dead silence when clinton's lawyer
is charged for starting the witch-hunt
again
the press just turns the page when the
plot thickens
and it's thickening
durham just slapped clinton's dirty
dossier law firm with more subpoenas
the fbi exposed again this week for
odious corruption
the ig report found the bureau
systematically lied and tricked the fisa
court for years into getting warrants to
spy on american citizens
they faked evidence hid evidence abuse
our privacy
and the media again hiding this sleaze
from the country
jim comey signed off on all of it but
the most corrupt fbi chief since hoover
skedaddled with a fat book deal and just
basks in the glow of left-wing worship
that's the retirement package when you
run the resistance
they're throwing it in our faces now
politico just confirmed hunter biden's
laptop was legit
and that's how you rig a vote
run the october surprise a year after
the election
so biden lied the family was in business
with the chinese communists and they
were holding 10 for the big guy
don't hold your breath for a prosecution
in arizona joe biden beat donald trump
by 11 000 votes
an audit in maricopa county done by an
outside firm found 57 000 questionable
ballots
just in that one county
the media wasn't interested in this
and the audience wasn't as thorough as
it could have been because arizona
officials wouldn't fully cooperate and
some evidence was removed and destroyed
so there's a dangerous pattern in the
united states politicians prosecutors
and the press are abusing their power to
wage political warfare against innocent
people
and even when the abuse is exposed the
press runs cover for the conspiracy
we're picking it apart
but we need more honest americans on the
inside
run for office be a reporter
i tell you to be a lawyer but this
country does not need any more lawyers
just the right ones in the right places
so get it right or be a judge
we can't win the battle from the outside
you know what you need to do
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else